hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
IPSC derived human neurons introduction
and application presented by Michael
Hendrickson a project manager at brain
cell incorporated I'm Suzy Valdez of
labret and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
brain cell for more information about
our sponsor visit them on their site at
WWF M before I begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
that appear on the screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located on a promotional board at
the bottom center of your screen or use
that ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process for obtaining those
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming our presenter today
Michael Hendrickson I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thanks so much for that introduction
Suzy and welcome everyone I hope that
the conference is treating you well so
far even though we're just getting
started and that everybody enjoys the
next couple of days and as soon as you
mentioned my the the title of my talk is
obviously direct human neurons
introduction and application and that's
really what I'm going to try to do in
this talk is to provide provide you with
a background in this technology really
from kind of a theoretical standpoint
and a very practical
and then also look at some applications
of the technology and will be in
particular discussing at the end of the
talk a case study in which we looked at
some drug screening paradigms using
these cells so a little bit of
background on myself I am as soon as you
mentioned a project manager and also an
application scientist at brain cell and
I've been with the company since its
inception in 2015 I have a background
and scene as drug development also in
neural development so I familiarity in
this area there's a picture of me there
this action shot on the on the right
side of the screen although today I've
cleverly hidden my bald head with this
beautiful headset so you can all hear me
well I can be contacted at any time by
email and very responsive so if you have
any questions about this talk or request
for the the slides which I think will be
made available or any other questions
about the technological area please
email me at the @m Hendrickson at brain
cell and that will also be at the end of
this presentation as well so let's let's
jump right in I'm going to tell you
about the topics we're going to cover
today I'm gonna provide you with a
little bit of a background about IPS see
reprogramming and the nature of their
pluripotency this won't be too technical
in this area because that's not our area
or my area of expertise but it'll give
you kind of a general idea of of how
that that technology works and then how
it fits into the main topic of
discussion today which is about neurons
derived from those cells and I'll talk
again a little bit about how the
differentiation is done again this is
going to be relatively general there are
a lot of protocols and publications you
can look up if you have specific
questions but I'll give you a good idea
of how that's typically done by our
group and also in the field in general
then we'll talk about
what types of neurons can be made using
this approach and discussed a little bit
about those different subtypes and then
for those of you who joined or attending
this this talk to learn a little bit
about the nuts and bolts of actually
using IPSC derived neurons I'm going to
provide kind of a summary of how they're
actually used in the lab with some with
some tips on use and that should I hope
you know maybe a swage some fears if
people are thinking about getting into
this area and also provide you some
ideas about how these need to be treated
these cells need to be treated a little
bit differently from some of the for
example cell lines or primary cells
people might have worked with in the
past I'm going to talk a little bit
about the application of these neurons
and then kind of hit on multiple
different topics multiple different
applications that that we've worked on
and also our collaborators and then as I
mentioned beginning I'm going to take
you through a high-throughput screening
campaign that we did using IPS II
derived motor neurons and that gives you
a little bit of an idea of real-world
application of these cells and some of
the challenges that we face and how we
address those so let's just jump right
in with some background information here
talking about IPS see reprogramming and
then we'll talk about neuronal
differentiation so this slide provides a
very general overview of this process
and really one thing if you're not
familiar with this area to remember is
that that IPS these are derived from
adults so so typically here what's done
is in theory any somatic cell can be
used but normally it's the other or a
fibroblast or blood cell PBMC is
harvested from an individual's this can
be an individual from age 1 to 100 can
be an individual who it you know it's
not suffering from any disease or an
individual with you know basically any
CNS or other disease
so once those cells are gathered they're
reprogrammed so they're taken from that
say fibroblast state into an IPS see
state and perhaps in mentioned this in
the talk about IPS C stands for induced
pluripotent stem cells and so there are
a number of ways to do this but in
general the the approach is to take
these so-called Yamanaka factors and
somehow get them expressed within the
cell as you can see here on the slide
there are a number of ways to do that
the most efficient ways at least to date
are to use some sort of viral
transduction so sendai virus is often
used you can also use an episome Allah
proach or a direct introduction of mRNAs
into the cells so this is a very rapidly
changing field and so that the
technologies are are coming out almost
on a monthly basis but in general you
this this approach is to get these you
know these sort of master transcription
factors into the cells that cause a
reprogramming really a reversion of the
cells to a much more primitive State and
so the they're the factors will change
the entire transcriptomic profile of the
cells and get them to that more
primitive pluripotent state so this is
where the name comes from right you're
inducing them into this pluripotent
state and from that point you can take
these cells and they can they're you
know proliferative so more of them can
be generated they're like uh stems you
know like as true stem cell they're very
similar to an embryonic stem cell but of
course not derived from an embryo and
that the process of D differentiation
can be reversed and that is we can take
the cells and then differentiate them so
that this talk will be entirely about
differentiating them to act to derm and
specifically to neuro ectoderm and then
specifically to neuronal and glial
subtypes so here we're talking about you
know differentiation to ectoderm n' and
specifically to the CNS and then
specifically to neurons of Kalea
so I prevents a little bit of similar
information but it gives you an idea of
the other areas in which these cells can
be can be differentiated too so in
theory IP SCS can be differentiated to
any cell type in the body and you know
sub cell type in the body but of course
today we're going to be focused
primarily on this lineage here which is
neuroectodermal to two neural cells and
the examples here are dopaminergic
neurons and motor neurons we'll talk in
a minute about some of the other cell
types that can be made so this is the
general scheme to get us to a neural
fate so our the the approach that our
group uses a general approach is laid
out in this schematic in which we begin
with an IPS see or an ESC culture and
those really as I mentioned can come
from anywhere and what what is done
typically here is really what's what's
called recapitulation of development so
you're using various factors and culture
techniques to pattern and drive the
cells into more and more specific fates
so we begin what we've labeled here is
an induction from the IPS see fate to a
neuropathy lleol progenitor fate this is
you know it's somewhat similar to a
neural stem cell fate basically a a
neural specific but still high potency
cell type that cell type is then driven
to a neuronal progenitor in our in our
protocol and so here we're producing a
specific neuronal progenitor so you may
have a motor neuron progenitor you may
have a glutamatergic neurons editor and
the way we approach this is we generate
large numbers of those progenitors which
then get converted into early neurons
those neurons can be differentiated and
matured really into mature neurons but
for purposes of distribution to our
colleagues and customers we freeze them
right at the stage where they're early
neurons and the bottom of the slide here
just has a little bit of a description
about the the number of cells that are
produced during this stage and so you
can start with a relatively small number
of IPS CS and produce a relatively large
number of neurons so this is kind of a
general approach that we use for all of
our neuron types and but I want to give
you kind of a sense of some of the of
the details so this is a published
example of doing an IPS see
differentiation to motor rods
and you so you see there in the left
where it says pfcs that's just a
pluripotent stem cell so it could be an
induced or an embryonic stem cell
and really here you're this is kind of
emphasizing the the techniques to
produce either rostral or caudal
neuropathy little progenitor cells and
then motor neurons with different
different phenotypes and so this is
something you can you know people can
certainly contact me off mind if they
like this publication or would request
more details but really the the thing to
keep in mind here is that the the IPC's
are driven down you're either ventral
izing or your dorsal izing or your your
rostra lysing or cauterizing to
eventually get the cell population of
interest right so you may be interested
in cells from the forebrain or from
behind brain or from the midbrain that's
all that needs to be taken into account
at the beginning of the process to end
up with neurons in the end that are the
type that you wanted to produce right so
these motor neurons in this situation
are caudally organized and so they're
going to be spinal bloggers neurons and
so these these neurons as as you they
are matured for one to two weeks in
culture begin to take on this beautiful
morphology and expression of motor
neuron markers so so this is just an
example but obviously we could step
through multiple neuron type
and provide the same kind of
differentiation and maturation to
produce very similar types of neurons so
the so these cells will have the classic
neuronal morphology and they will
express the neural proteins of interest
which are detailed right below the
figures there and there really this is
again to provide you an example of the
the morphology and the phenotype of
these neurons at the end of the process
right as I mentioned this can be used
this this technology can be used for
many neuron types and so we've already
talked a little bit about spinal motor
neurons but of course midbrain
dopaminergic neurons can also be made
these were some of the earliest cells to
be made using this kind of technology we
and others produce cortical GABAergic
neurons which have a variety of subtypes
including part of the boolean positive
neurons and somatostatin of neurons and
also of course cortical glutamatergic
neurons and these could be mixed
together to produce the 80/20 mixture
that is seen in a in vivo condition
these cells using contemporary
technology can be generated with a very
high overall neuronal purity and they
can also the the neuronal subtype so for
example you know the percentage of all
your neurons that are motor neurons that
purity can also be very high when done
when the differentiations are done in a
very controlled way and as I hinted at
and in several slides ago very large
scales are possible and we'll talk a
little bit about that at the end of the
presentation when we're focusing on the
the screening campaign that we did the
types I've talked about so far are more
general types we and others have begun
to produce very specific types of
neurons and astrocytes so striatal
medium spiny GABAergic neurons can be
made as well as layer specific cortical
neurons so we can make very high purity
layer five cortical neurons which are
involved in some diseases of the CNS and
brain serotonergic neurons are another
type that are can can be made that are
not commonly encountered in this area
and as well we can bank cortical and
spinal asha sites again many types are
possible so other groups produce sensory
and peripheral neurons and we and others
are also working to produce microglia
and other types of macro kalenna so
again in in theory any neuron specific
type in the brain can be made these are
some examples of types of we've worked
on in the past so something that's very
powerful as it relates to the use of IPS
CS is the ability to generate neurons
from patients so as I mentioned before
the IPS T's can be generated basically
from any individual and regardless of
age or disease status and the same
protocols that are used to make the
normal you know or wild-type neurons can
also be used from disease IPS CS that is
seized from from patients and just an
example here you know you could make
motor neurons from ALS lines that have
been a mutation for sod1 or c9 or 72 can
make glutamatergic neurons from
niemann-pick lines and you could make
medium spiny neurons from Huntington's
disease lines and obviously the
possibilities here are endless and
that's something that we and other
groups have been working on just as kind
of a practical guide if you're out there
and you're thinking oh you know this
sounds kind of interesting I'd like to
do this it can be you know potentially a
little bit daunting to figure out where
to get the IPS C's potentially the lab
down the hall has them but also we've
gotten them mostly from bio banks and so
I just wanted to mention a couple here
that we've used in the past and that
would be n IDs and cedars-sinai
the ni NDS bio Bank in particular has
been very useful for us and so I just
wanted to give them another plug and you
can see the the website there at the
bottom of your screen if you just google
an IDs bio bank you'll also find it very
easily so they have a wide range of ips
CS and fibroblasts and other cell types
and tissue you know tissue samples from
a range of patients and so that can be a
very useful resource let's say you're at
the point where you produce some of
these cells or you've purchased some of
these cells and you're working with them
actually in the laboratory and so this
is you know can always be nice and in
these presentations I think to give a
little idea of actually you know how
it's done and one of the things I need
to think about especially for those of
you who work at the bench so I'll try to
do that and I'll try to provide some
tips and some very practical advice as
we go through this so the first thing
that you need to think about is you know
how you're gonna culture these and I'll
just talk about from a commercial source
what what people receive is a at least
from us and from others there's gonna be
a vial of neurons and typically we're
talking about single-digit millions of
neurons and a certain fill volume and of
course these are stored in the liquid
nitrogen storage is important because
these are our overall very sensitive
cells so how you gonna plate them what
you're gonna do
really depends on the experiment at hand
so we have collaborators who plate these
cells in very large wells because they
need a lot of protein for a low abundant
target of course they could be plated
you know commonly in 96-well format for
imaging for cellular assays for
viability assays that's a format we use
very commonly and even our guides talk
about using that format however they can
also be used in very high throughput
formats we've been successful in using
them in 1536 well format some of our
collaborators are even starting to do
that do some imaging
and other screening in that format the
course they can be used in specialty
formats such as multi-electrode array
plates or other specialty chambers much
microfluidic chambers or co-culture
chambers so I'll talk a little bit about
some of those more esoteric applications
later in the talk and really using these
cells if you follow certain guidelines
can actually be very easy because there
isn't any passage involved so because
they're terminally differentiated cells
you really just have to saw them count
them dilute them and plate them out and
of course wherever you plate them is
where they're going to end up because
they can't be lifted and passage our
medium that we use is presented here and
this is really just for reference if you
have this you know you can get the
slides later and have a look this is
also available on our website a few
things I want to point out is that it's
best to have the medium freshly prepared
and in our protocol we use a small
amount of gel tracks or Maitre gel
dissolved into the media itself and we
found that provides better adherence for
the neurons and also improves neuronal
outgrowth as well or neuro outgrowth I
should say and in provide at least from
us with our ourselves our is a specialty
supplement that helps with maturation we
recommend PDL coated plates we typically
don't need or recommend using laminate
PDL we find provides a nice balance of
giving good adherence of the cells but
also not necessarily encouraging them to
migrate and clump together so that's a
common problem with when using these
types of cells to get a lot of clumping
of the cells and typically for most
assays you'd want nice evenly
distributed cells and you can coat these
yourselves which is what we do but
they're also PDL plates are also
obviously commercially available I'll
just mention this quickly but we and
others have developed specialty
supplements that assist
and with keeping neurons alive after
thawing and also making sure that the
progenitors convert if there any
remaining late stage pretenders that
they all become neurons and that those
neurons accelerate rapidly okay so let's
say you have these neurons in in the
laboratory and you want to actually use
them I'll just give you some some really
practical tips about using them
something to think about if you're
designing an experiment so as I
mentioned they are the neurons are
relatively it's sensitive to the
temperature in the sense that they can't
be stored in a minus eighty right so
they need to be stored either in an
ultra low temperature freezer or in
liquid nitrogen which is commonly done
they can be shipped over short periods
on dry ice for some of the neuron types
and of course everyone says keep the
cells in the vapor phase but we've had
no problem storing them in the liquid
phase so if you're thawing cells this is
an important point I tell our
collaborators and our customers is to
make sure that you don't over incubate
the cells so they are very sensitive to
temperatures that are too hot so you can
cook quick them very kill them very
quickly by going over 37 degrees and so
if you have any concerns or nervous
about it I recommend people that they
turn their water bath down a little bit
and when you're thawing if you remove
when there's just a tiny bit of ice left
that's the perfect time because by the
time you get it into the hood that last
little bit will have melt it and you're
ready to go as I mentioned using them is
relatively straightforward if you're
cautious and so the next step is simply
to dilute the cells up and you do that
very slowly in a drop-wise manner you
gently swirl you don't shake the tube or
trigger rate up and down so we're trying
to avoid osmotic shock and as I
mentioned the last slide also
temperature shock as well as physical
shear of the cells so if you treat them
well with at the beginning of your
experiment they'll perform really well
at the end for you you would count these
cells in the same way that you would
count really in each cell type you're
working with there's much of a
difference
and doing the counting and the diluting
up and although one thing to keep in
mind is that the viability will not be
as great as you would see from some cell
lines for example so typical viability
is in the eighty to fifty percent range
if you see people talking about 95 or 99
percent viability I would treat that
with a grain of salt that's a little
suspect because these cells are not the
hardiest and and they will not survive
that freeze-thaw process without at
least some cell death and also I would
recommend the people note what the
supplier provides as far as the number
of cells that are either frozen or
viable because obviously there's a big
difference there in this example we're
plating the cells using a multi-channel
pipette into a 96-well plate most times
people that use these cells are going to
be using plates and there's a general
rule of thumb 1 million to 2 million
cells per plate is kind of where you
want to be when thinking about an
experiment for example depend obviously
depending on the assay that will change
a little bit but that's a general rule
of thumb if you're thinking about how
many cells you might eat for an
experiment and one little trick we use
is that we typically will very gently
plate into the the wells and then leave
that plate in the hood let it sit let
the cells settle down
evenly and attach and you'll get a much
more evenly distributed culture doing it
that way you won't end up with cells in
the middle of the well because the the
plate is being shaken you also won't end
up with temperature gradients causing
cells to distribute elsewhere because
they're in the incubator incubation is
standard with these cells there are some
groups that use low low oxygen
incubators we haven't found that that's
necessary although one challenge we do
face in this area and others use is to
maintain a very high humidity and it's
particularly problematic with long term
cultures in 384 or 1536 well format so
that's something to keep in mind
especially if you're going or then
a few days in 1536 or more than a few
weeks in 384 is that you're going to
have that edge effect from evaporation
another general rule of thumb working
with these cells is the fewer changes
you can get away with fewer media
changes you can get away with the better
the neurons don't like to be shocked and
so change is just twice a week are
perfectly sufficient for these cells
just to recap some of these practical
tips very quickly we recommend using
freshly prepared media to the recipe
that we recommend or others and our
recipe is relatively standard we also
recommend using freshly coated plates
and that you either coat yourself or get
from a commercial supplier we've
actually found that the ones we cut
ourselves are a little bit better and as
I mentioned many times already treat the
cells very gently if you treat them like
an indestructible immortalised - Merline
they they won't be happy if you treat
them very gently you're really gonna get
a beautiful culture out of them and also
remember that whatever vessel you plate
them into is where you're going to need
to run your experiment right so they
can't be lifted and transferred without
killing 95 or 99 percent of the cells
I'd like to talk a little bit about some
applications of our neurons that our
collaborators are working on and this is
these are really in no particular order
and or no particular level of importance
but this gives you an idea of the kinds
of things that can be done with our
neurons really across a range of
experiments so the first one I'll talk
about I mentioned a little bit earlier
when referring to the specialty types of
plates is a multi electrode array
experiment also called an MBA or some
people say Mia experiment
these are array plates that
look like a typical microtiter plate but
they have embedded in the bottom of the
well an electrode array and that
electrode array could vary by the
supplier of these plates and their
technology in there there there several
around here you can see that one of our
collaborators works with accion
obviously and they're they're reputable
supplier for this kind of technology in
general these to run these kinds of
experiments the neurons are seeded at
very high density and you can they may
be cultured for actually relatively long
periods of time although in in several
of our experiments we've seen activity
that's that's coming up at about a week
so so some of the experience can be run
relatively early as well astrocytes in
general improve the activity of the
these cultures although they don't need
to be run with astrocytes and sort of
leveraging the power of disease modeling
the these kind of experiments can of
course be run with disease cells
compared to in normal cells and that's
something that people are are looking at
very closely and so I just wanted to
provide you with a little very little
example data here so this is just a
quick time a single time point heat map
from an MEA experiment that we we did
in-house and you could see the the white
spots there are the actual electrodes
where there's a high level of activity
and then on the the right side of the
slide to give you an idea of what this
looks like through time is a time course
of spike trains over 16 electrodes you
could see here actually if you you know
kind of look at these traces that
there's activities kind of synchronized
to some extent whatever that is every 30
seconds or something like that so you
can get really robust activity and here
we're talking about cultures that are
one to two weeks old so this is really
looking more closely at the functional
activity of the neurons rather than say
protein expression or you know
expression of a certain receptor
also on the functional side one area
that can be studied is to look at the
calcium influx of these cells you can
load with a calcium die calcium
indicator dye and you can either do
traditional microscopic imaging or you
can also do Holwell imaging so these are
examples from the hammam Otsu instrument
looking at very long-term neuronal
cultures for which calcium oscillations
can be induced using several
pharmacologic agents here we're looking
really at Network kind of level activity
right you're looking at oscillatory
activity within the cultures themselves
and this this kind of activity
potentially could be parsed for a
disease versus a normal condition these
you know building these kind of disease
and a dish sort of systems really here
looking at Network overall Network level
activity if this this kind of experiment
is done using imaging you get images
like this I've got a nice video of this
which can't be used here but to show
sort of pulsing activity and oscillatory
activity through time so it can be done
both as a kind of a homogeneous Holwell
collection of signal versus an imaging
assay as well using a calcium dye so
here we're looking at very long-term
cultures but acute changes that are not
related to an oscillatory activity in
the cultures can also be examined using
various pharmacological agents so this
is just a really an example of a quick
experiment we ran with a these were
maybe day 10 or day 12 neurons you
applying different agents and looking
for changes in the culture following
electrical stimulation again this is
looking at calcium influx but here
you're looking at more of a real-time
kind of pharmacologic response rather
than a whole network activity really
interesting application of these cells
is high-content imaging there
they're beautiful cells and actually
they make for really good sources of
imaging they're not the easiest cells to
image but with a little bit of effort
the the data that comes out or can be
really useful so we have produced
neurons that have a stable expressed GFP
these cells can be cultured for one to
two weeks and various compounds could be
applied for as an example and then
images can be collected so this is you
know I know this is difficult to see but
this is an example kind of raw data you
would get and so potentially you know a
very large number of images can be
collected I think this group was
collecting four images per well in the
384-well plate so you know with one
plate you're quickly above a thousand
images so obviously you need some
computer assistance do the analysis and
so here on the left side of the screen
you can see a control neuronal culture
with nice beautiful neurites extending
from the cells and the right side you
can see a rotenone treated culture so
you can use some high content imaging
software to help identify the cell
bodies in these images and then from
there the computer can build a trace of
where the neurites are those nights can
be then be quantified so you can measure
length and branch points and all sorts
of parameters to your heart's delight
and when this group did that they they
were able to see not a huge difference
between the number of neurons in each
well looking over time you know with
rotenone concentration versus normal
versus you know untreated but the neuron
length really provided a relatively
large window but between treated and non
treated especially at the 48-hour time
point and so they were able to generate
a really high Z prime for this assay and
they're currently taking this into even
higher formats so this has been you know
one of the more interesting applications
that one of our collaborators looked at
for neuro Texas makes
experiments can be done again looking at
high high content kind of format so this
is just an example of a
acetylcholinesterase assay that was done
and converted from 384 to 1536 with very
similar
ic50 scores this the same group was also
interested in looking at the neurons
cubed motor neurons compared to a human
neuroblastoma cell line and and this is
something I'll come back to before the
motor neurons are much more relevant
system although the response they get is
a little bit muted compared to the SHS
y5y cells and you can see that by
looking at the scale of these graphs and
so that's something just that I think is
important to think about especially if
you're looking at drug development
really any situation once you're using a
model system is to the extent that your
response or whatever is is being studied
changes as you use more relevant systems
and so often sadly what we see right is
that something that's studied in a cell
line maybe the response is less in a a
true neuron line or true
primary or IPSC derived neurons and that
may affect may fall off even further
when a drug or treatment is taken into
man so that's always something to keep
in mind with whatever model system
you're working it and finally just to
mention it that transfection is
certainly possible in these cells and we
can actually get using lentivirus
relatively high levels transfection
non-viral methods are also possible but
the transmission efficiency low is is
lower this is something we're currently
working on collaboration with another
company to try to get that number up but
it's a really truly straightforward
procedure involves simply adding the
virus at the start of the culture so for
the last part of the talk here I'd like
to walk everyone through a
high-throughput screening case study
that we did and again for those of you
are interested in screening this
the I think of a particular interest but
also help to kind of highlight some of
the challenges of working with these
cells and and how to address them we did
this in collaboration with the National
Center for advancing translational
sciences which is also called n cats at
the NIH and we produce a very large
number of neurons with this screen and
we looked at what for us was a large
number of compounds I know some groups
have looked at more compounds into the
millions but this was a large screen for
us that we did from five libraries with
a little help from a robot and the
overall rationale here as I alluded to a
little bit before is that we want we
encourage all of our collaborators all
of our customers to use the model system
that's most relevant and feasible for
the experiments they're currently doing
and so our view is that in an effort to
kind of reduce the high rates of drug
attrition especially in the cns area
which is highly costly using systems
like IPSC derived neurons as early in
the process as possible can potentially
help lower that rate of return and
produce compounds that are more viable
in the clinic and so for this experiment
the model system we're going to use are
IPSC derived human motor neurons we've
already talked a little bit about about
those cells that they have a complex
morphology and they express the the
markers of interest but the disease were
interested in screening for this for
compounds for in this case was spinal
muscular atrophy which is really a
devastating childhood illness and it can
be fatal in type 1 patients not fatal in
type 2 and and so on the disease has
relatively straightforward genetics and
balls of mutation and the SM smn1 gene
and most approaches to treat the disease
have focused on increasing the amount of
the smn2
team that's produced so there's this
potential rescue effect that can be
achieved if the smn2 level of protein
can be enhanced and so most approaches
have folks focused on looking at the
splice variants changing the splice
variants for the smn2 protein that's
also the approach that we took so we
built a relatively complicated recorder
system in which if the full-length smn2
was expressed we would also get the
expression of our reporter which in this
case is nano luciferase so this system
was a a knockin system at one allele at
the endogenous site so really produces a
physiologically relevant response I just
want to give a quick plug to kromega an
ELISA phrase here because it's really
performed very very well in our hands
it's it's more or less as advertised so
this is a very bright reporter if
anybody's looking to build their own
reporter system certainly have a look at
it it's very bright and also I'll show a
little bit data in a second that the
false positive rate is in our hands was
very very low Fernan ELISA phrase which
is not the case for with all of the
phrases
our reporter system responded to the
positive controls that we were able to
get our hands on so these are both
compounds in development to treat SMA to
treat SMA and the efficacy that we
observed was about 50 to 60 percent and
we had a relatively low C prime for a
96-well format but because the system is
very clean we decided to move ahead and
do the high throughput screening so
these details we don't have to get too
involved with but to give you a general
sense as the screening is done over a
relatively short period of time but even
over this period of just a few days you
know the cells have already sent sent
out pretty long neurites and are have a
morphology that's relatively mature that
doesn't mean the neurons are fully
mature but from a protein expression a
morphological standpoint they have a
reasonable level of maturity
so here you can see in the upper right
there just a quick image of these cells
in the 1536 well format and one thing I
too to emphasize here is that the these
neurons were built from that reporter
line that reporter line was built on IPS
sees from an SMA patient so we're really
looking at motor neurons with a reporter
system from an SMA patient to have that
proper genetic background in this case
even though we would have liked to have
used PDL coated plates we actually had
to use uncoated plates but because of
the timeline of the experiment which is
relatively short and because we were
able to put a little mate Rogell into
the seating medium we were able to to
deal with the uncoated place that's of
course something we had tested
beforehand for these experiments we used
an approach called quantitative
high-throughput screening and so here
really what you're doing is you're
getting a dose response curve for each
compound and that can be for for some of
the libraries up to 11 points but also
yeah typically done at say five or six
concentrations it really helps you to
rule out even single point deviations of
course that means running more Wells but
for our system in which the window was
relatively small this is really a very
helpful approach to use and it's an
approach that n cats uses quite often
this is a little bit of an example data
from the NPC a library a couple things I
want to point out here as I mentioned
that we didn't have a very large window
using our positive control compound but
the system is very very clean and what
that means is we were able to pluck out
possible hits without worrying about
pulling out a very large number of
positive controls especially when you
would go in and remove you know
potential outliers as these because they
were caused by a a error in seating at
the so called multi
right Eric seating the plates initially
so as soon as we moved removed those
artifacts the number of compounds we had
to deal with was relatively small we're
able to get overall very good Seavey's
across the libraries and this helps
keeping the system clean because again
here we're looking at a response of
around 40% a little bit under 40% for
the positive control so we needed a
clean system in order to be able to see
those those possible hits so even with
these numbers the Z prime is relatively
low but again with a little bit of
curation of the data we were able to
pull all some potentially interesting
compounds and so we had a low one kind
of kind of a wide net our hit rate was
about 5% when we would look through
those hits using the quantitative data
we reduced that to about 0.5% and they
were able to remove compounds that were
true hits but uninteresting so these
would be compounds an inhibited protein
breakdown so in here in this case
obviously we're looking for the increase
in the level of a protein so if you have
compounds that are protease inhibitors
they're you know potentially will
produce a physiological increase in that
protein but are not interesting you know
therapeutically and unfortunately we
were we weren't able to confirm any hits
from these screening which is not
terribly surprising because this is
known to be a relatively difficult
target so that's just a quick example of
a screening campaign that that we did
and of course people can contact me
offline if you'd like more information
about it
but I just wanted to before we get to
any questions to summarize what we
talked about today and so I really want
to emphasize the fact that our view is
that the IPSC derived human neurons in
many cases present a more
physiologically relevant model systems
both for normal physiology and
pathophysiology especially compared to
you know unusual neuron like cells pc-12
cells and neuroblastoma cells the other
thing that's important is that these
cells can be used much in the same way
you would use those kinds of cells but
just a little bit of extra care and a
little extra caution and some foresight
need to be taken but it's not something
that should be overly intimidating and
these neurons are amenable to a range of
applications and you know here I've
highlighted a few but obviously most
cell assays that can be done can be done
with these neurons and again they all
also are feasible to do large-scale
screening with them and so before we
take any questions I want to just thank
our entire brain cell team who helped me
put this all together as well as our
collaborators at various labs around the
world really and I'll leave my contact
information up here and I think it's
also available probably in the in the
notes in a lecture notes but feel free
to contact me really with any questions
about the of the talk or this
technological area and if there any
questions I think we can take them now
thank you Michael for that informative
presentation we will now start a live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
and take a look at our incoming
questions from our audience members our
first question Michael is what kind of
purity can be achieved and how is it
measured okay that's that's a good
question that's a question we get often
and I think in one of the slides I just
talked about high purity right and so in
at least for for the the cells that we
produce and I can really only
specifically speak to them the overall
their neuronal purity that can be
achieved it is
can be tremendously high so they can be
higher than 95% and in many cases they
could be higher than 98 or 99% so that's
one way of looking at periods is out of
all the cells how many are neurons but a
a more important way or an additional
ways you think about purity is what
percentage of those neurons are the
subtype I'm interested in and so that
can range depending upon you know
whether we're talking about motor
neurons or dopaminergic neurons and so
on so typically what what we we see is
ranges from fifty to eighty percent for
those those subtype specific purity
levels how long do the neurons need to
grow before they can be used all right
so this is another good question this is
a question we get all the time and I
wish I could provide a simple answer but
it's really highly dependent on what you
need to do so you you saw in my
presentation that I present the data
from as soon as three or four days after
thawing so in the in the in the
screening application we did you know we
could get a nice response for a positive
control at just day four after thawing
you also saw some data looking at
Network calcium oscillations
that's from taken from seven weeks so
those really kind of provide you know
bookends of of the the timeline needed
for an experiment so the more
physiologic or the moral
electrophysiological activity the more
network activity one needs probably the
longer one has to look seven weeks would
sort of be the at the outside edge of
that for most cell assay cell you know
we're dealing with looking at most
receptors protein levels viability
assays we run most of those assay
starting at day seven and concluding at
day ten or day fourteen so most of those
are done within a couple weeks after
thawing but again it really is highly
dependent on the
exact needs of your experiment thank you
Michael
we have time for a couple more questions
and I want to remind audience members
whatever questions aren't answered today
will be answered via email our next
question from our audience member is can
they be used to make brain organoids
or 3d I'm sorry 3d cultures yeah so this
is the this aspect of the field is
really coming on strong especially in
the last two or three years so we
haven't done a lot of work in this area
growing organoids or 3d cultures the
cells certainly can as some of our
collaborators are starting to look at
this now one of the reasons we haven't
jumped into this area with with both
feet is that it can be very difficult to
analyze those cells at the other end
it's certainly a very interesting
technology but adding the additional
dimension when it comes to analysis when
it comes to consistency as well adds a
huge challenge that I think is
potentially underappreciated by some
people so the cells certainly can be
used to generate 3d cultures but it's
not something we have a lot of
experience in at least at this time
thank you for that we have a final
question can they be cultured with CLIA
or non neural cells yeah that's that's a
that's a good question this straight for
straightforward answer is yes so we and
our collaborators often do cultures with
neurons and astrocytes and some of our
some of the groups we work with actually
do cultures of say human motor neurons
are human glutamatergic neurons with rat
primary astrocytes so certainly
co-cultures with neurons and glia are
possible
in addition for their other possible
combinations so for example culturing
motor neurons with skeletal muscle is
certainly some
it's been tried by several of our
collaborators and is feasible as well so
those kinds of co-culture experiments
and you know starting to build kind of
organ on the chip type cultures are are
absolutely feasible yes thank you
Michael and would you like to provide
any closing remarks for our audience
before we close today I would just say
you know I encourage anybody to contact
me I'm actually you know I'm obviously
representing a commercial supplier but
we will help anybody with any questions
they have and and point them in the
direction that will help them so feel
free to contact me with any questions
and start thinking about whether these
cells may you know enhance the kind of
research you're doing because we do feel
really strongly that more relevant model
systems including ESD drive human
neurons will help to improve the
translation of technologies particularly
drug development from model systems to
the clinic to the bedside thank you so
much Michael and thank you for this
informative presentation in your
important research we also want to thank
our students our brain cell and I'd like
to thank collaborates for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to thank everyone and let them
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 2018 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know that the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thanks
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye thank you Susie